I want to break up with you what to do
now
[Music]
hello
is everything okay you have mascara
built over your whole face you actually
have like a piece of toilet paper other
side there yeah just got dumped I want
to break up with you
I'm breaking up with you
how about this whatever we're feeling
like we just can't take it anymore
let's call each other for each other's
sadness sisters well sadness sisters
sounds like you're Diane Keaton and I'm
Meryl Streep and we're in a Broadway
play but oh I get yeah that's a great
cast
you should cast plays
oh my God and look at her with my
boyfriend this is bad
what the [ __ ] here is the love of my
life the Anne is the love of mine but
I'm not so sure that they're gonna
realize it not with these shiny new
people around so what are we supposed to
do
I have to break them up that's crazy we
can't do that
how would we do that
I will seduce Anne's boyfriend am I
doing this right it's so wet you just
take your two fingers let it drip out oh
thank you I don't think we've met hi oh
friendship seduce Noah what about your
ex really funny was she funny pop that
shirt off I'd rather not I'll tell you
what I'll take mine off too that's not
gonna help me at all
can I tell you a little secret about
being an adult
pretending that we know what we're doing
and we're hoping that we don't screw it
up he's stamina's really improved that's
the drugs I find you both incredibly
attractive oh yeah
yeah
wow
work yeah man I'm a psycho
[Music]
[Music]
you are somebody that a person could
fall very deeply in love with but it's
more like slowly over five or six months
okay or like a year
two years top do you realize the numbers
going up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]